je la joue du marron très
c'est un triste à mourir
mais reconnaît dans mes pensées
non première rencontre
edith piaf ou le succès
m
quand on est tous les deux la bonne
no
réveil lui raconter en quarante quatre c
est dit était très jolie et ses chambres
vous l'avez d'arrêt au milieu comme ça
et je sais pas qui l'avait tellement que
je à l'intérieur tellement énorme que
moi je la trouve très belle
et lorsqu'elle m'a vu la première fois
où la rouge nous sommes passés ensemble
ce qui est vrai et ou des découvertes
mais aussi pour la première fois car je
n'aimais pas du tout je pense est une
chanteuse de cafards et c est elle dit
qu'est ce que ce conte un pays s'il dont
on nous rabat les oreilles qui ceci cela
si vous voulez nous avons eu je m'excuse
salaires prétentieux comme ça une forme
de deux d'estimé d'eux et de sympathie
réciproque tout de suite dès qu'il y
avait un garçon qui sortait qui avait
quelque chose est dite par amour du
métier
hors amont des hommes mais par amour du
métier très souvent c'était toujours ça
que tu as déterminée au départ elle veut
des l'éclairer de son projecteur en
quelque sorte dit automatiquement vous
était donc pris dans le faisceau de
biens sans renie en rien ce qu'elle a pu
m'apporter les rapports avec piaf mais
je crois même dans les petites choses
très passionnel n'osons passionnel mais
tellement formidable est tellement jolie
mésaventure qu'a pu avoir les dites
c'est que elle chantait formidablement
bien lorsqu elle est amoureuse et
formellement bien lorsqu'elle était en
rupture et je crois que je succombe
sûrement elle a pensé devait le sentir
d'elle-même dans deux choses c'est
pourquoi je pense tous ces sortes d'
aventure et non pas du tout pour une
question de vice est une question de ce
pas vrai du tout en quelque sorte pour
elle l'amour du père ma tête parce
endroit absolument absolument mais dans
une très grande piloter une chose que
n'amène pas éditer tu es une fille qui
ne pourraient pas aller se coucher le
soir sans faire sa prière par exemple
sur sa formidable pour une fille comme
source extraordinaire
moi je crois pas elle croyait que sa
très jolie est dit était un personnage
tellement entier tellement s'anime eu
tellement généreux très cruel ne pouvait
être vraiment gens pour le moins
bon escient mais je pense pas que les
gens soient uniquement que gentil gentil
était dans l est et comme il était où la
légende qu'ils ont écrits qu'on a
raconté à l'époque que j'avais quitté
pas du tout bel et bien elle qui m'a
laissé tomber et puis très très durement
même